An important transition.
Today we're going to start talking about the social contract tradition.
We've come a long way,
it's still only February,
but you've really worked through two of the major enlightenment traditions of
thinking about political theory.
Two.
To get into the social contract tradition,
we have to go back again to lock it.
We said kind of hovering presence throughout the whole course and locks idea of
workmanship,
which we thought about mainly in relation to creation of objects of value,
the theory of property in lock,
uh,
and how that plays itself out in,
in the labor theory of value developed by marks that we've been talking about
for some time,
uh,
over the past couple of weeks.
Well,
alongside the,
the uh,
economic of workmanship,
if you like,
that goes back to lock.
There's a politics of workmanship because just as we own what we make in the
material sense in lock story,
we also own the political institutions that we create.
And if you cast your minds back to the early lectures I gave on the
enlightenment project,
um,
a big part of,
of,
um,
that claim was that we can have maker's knowledge of the political institutions
we create just as we have maker's knowledge of the economic social relations
that we create,
economic and social relations that we create.
And not only do we have maker's knowledge so we can have this kind of certainty
the early enlightenment theorists were looking for,
but we also have makers authority over what we create.
Remember I told you that Loc was engaged in this,
um,
debate with other natural law theorist in the 1660s,
where the big question was whether or not God is omnipotent.
Um,
and the question was then if you said God is omnipotent,
it seemed to threaten the timelessness of natural law because he'd been a
position to change it.
Uh,
on the other hand,
if you said that,
uh,
God does not have the power to change natural law that seem to undermine his
omnipotence.
So either omniscient,
if,
I mean either the timelessness of natural law or the omnipotence of God.
But you seem like you couldn't have both.
And locks wrestled with this question his whole life.
But in the end came down on what's sometimes called the voluntourist side that
will dependent side decide which got them into the whole workmanship ideal.
So we know what we make and we own what we make because God gave us to be a able
to op the capacity to be able to operate as miniature gods and to operate,
uh,
in a godlike fashion,
creating a institutions and economic relationships and social relationships over
which we have the same kind of control with the caveat that we as God's
property,
we're bound by,
uh,
God's,
wishes,
which appeared to us as natural law.
Whereas in the things we create,
so long as we don't violate those constraints as assets,
God's creatures,
um,
we,
we're not,
we can do what we like and that,
that is the idea that informs Locke's argument in the second treaties where he
says,
mmm,
to remind you,
there's no earthly authority that can settle disputes about natural law.
And so it's,
it's every person for themself.
Uh,
if,
if there really isn't disagreement,
and I'll,
I'll come back to the implications of that more fully later when we talk about
majority rule.
Um,
but the,
the most important point to take away for right now is that we are constrained
by natural law in the natural law tradition,
um,
because with God's property and he has make us knowledge over his creation,
which we are,
but with the constraint,
well with the caveat that he rejects the traditional idea
that,
uh,
he was arguing against filmer and others about that there's anybody,
whether it's the Pope or the king or anybody else who has the right to say what
natural law means in the case of a dispute.
And that's the beginning of modern individualism for Loc
that,
uh,
we are,
we're miniature.
God's on the one hand.
And yes,
we constrained by natural law,
but it's not much of a constraint really because we're the ones who get to say,
uh,
what natural law means in a disputed circumstance.
Um,
so,
uh,
the individual comes into the center of thinking about politics now.
Okay.
Um,
Nozick Robert Nozick is as a person,
we're going to use to ease our way into modern social contract theory.
In a way it's an odd choice because Nozick is actually a critic of John Rawls
who are going to read next and probably wouldn't have even written the book that
he wrote.
Um,
but for the existence of roles as book to which he was reacting.
But I'm choosing Nozick to do Nozick first,
but for pedagogical reasons,
one is because Nozick explicitly built off a lockin set of intuitions.
Uh,
and secondly,
because his of the social contract is another variation of the reits utilities
synthesis that we looked at in connection with Mel.
But it's,
it's one that purports to solve the main problem that we were left within male,
which is the Marxian Critique of marks it market.
You know,
we,
uh,
if you recall from the end of our discussion of marks,
we said that one of the things that is left untouched by all the problems with
marks is Marxists critique of markets from the standpoint of the status quo,
the starting points problem,
the garbage in,
garbage out problem that that if you have,
uh,
an unjust status quo and then a lot of market transactions,
all those transactions are going to be infected by the injustice that goes into
this status quo.
If the corn dealer really is as starver of the poor,
uh,
to use a male's example in the chapter on free speech,
Nozick thinks he has an answer to that.
Nozick thinks that he has a reformulation of the reits utilities synthesis that
answers that problem and you will only get to how he thinks he had,
how he thinks.
He answers that problem next Monday.
But he thinks that he has an answer and in fact,
it's a brilliant answer and even those of you who don't like that answer are
going to find it very difficult to respond to nozicks point.
Um,
but before getting into the details of nozicks argument,
uh,
I think it's,
it's worth just pausing for a minute to notice two problems that any social
contract theory has and has long been known to have,
which anybody who tries to come up with a social contract theory has to deal
with.
Um,
it's long been known first of all that because there never was an actual social
contract,
that assumptions you make about natural men tend to be loaded with assumptions
about human beings from your own society.
This,
this critique is maybe not as old as the hills,
but it certainly as old as as Russo's critique of Hobbes writing in the 18th
century Russo said,
the problem with Hobbes is Leviathan,
which is another version of the social contract that we're not reading in this
course.
Russo said,
the problem with Leviathan is that Hobbes takes assumptions from the people of
his own day and attributes them to natural man projects them on to the idea of
natural man.
And you can't do that.
And so we're,
so his own version of the social contract is much more historical.
Um,
it,
it attempts to take account of the evolution of people from some kind of a pre,
almost pre human condition where to a condition in which social and political
relationships evolve.
Um,
but this,
this claim is made time and again,
when people talk about the social contract,
uh,
as,
as moving from a condition of,
um,
pre natural,
pre political man to a social and political condition,
people say,
well,
the problem with it is Russo's problem with Hobbs.
That what people in fact do is take a set of assumptions about human beings that
are the product of the society that's been created and attribute them to natural
man.
And so you get this problem that,
uh,
what you put into it is,
it's a,
it's a different but related kind of garbage in,
garbage out problem.
The assumptions you make about human nature,
uh,
are,
are taken from,
uh,
the society.
You want to justify a when in fact,
um,
that and then you present them as,
as though they weren't features of natural,
uh,
human nature,
of,
of pretty social,
if you like,
human nature.
And,
and so the argument goes,
what we now know from 200 years of anthropology's that actually Aristotle was
right.
There never was a pre social condition.
Human beings are naturally social creatures and you can analyze them apart from
their social and cultural environment.
You just can't do it.
Uh,
anything you try to do in that general direction will be,
um,
it will obscure more than it reveals.
You'll end up with a 10 dentures assumptions about human nature that will allow
you to derive the conclusions that you want.
But at the end of the day,
this is only going to persuade the people who agreed with you before you began.
And it's not going to convince the skeptics.
So what's the point?
So this is one problem that has long been known to attend social contract
theory.
And,
um,
anybody who's gonna roll one out has to deal with it.
And what you find with the modern social contract theorists like Nozick and
roles is they say,
granted,
we don't disagree that there never was a social contract.
And indeed,
even if you look at the,
those of you who are students of American history,
well now,
even if you look at the social contract that came the closest to being an actual
social contract equate as society,
namely the creation of the American republic,
even there,
um,
if you look up,
it didn't come about as the result of an agreement.
The,
the federal constitution was put in place in violation of the articles of
confederation and was largely imposed by the federalist horses who was stronger
than the anti federalist than the,
than the confederation forces.
So,
um,
even the American example,
which is the one that inspires,
knows book is not a case of a creation of a,
of a society from whole cloth by agreement.
It's neither out of whole cloth because they were ready social and political
arrangements before and it's not ready by agreement because it was imposed on
those who didn't want it.
Pretty much by force.
Um,
we'll come back to the extent at which to which it was imposed later,
but the basic fact remains.
Nozick knows all of that.
He's not a fool and he's not ignorant.
But he says,
let's suppose society could be created by unanimous agreement,
could be created by consent.
What would it look like?
And we're not saying pre,
pre political,
pre social beings,
people like you and me.
If we were in a situation where there was no state,
what kind of state,
if any,
would we create?
And we'll see when we come to do John Rawls,
uh,
after the break,
he has the same approach.
It's not an,
it's not the people often get roles and Nozick wrong.
They're not saying,
oh,
the,
we can imagine what people would be like if a state didn't exist.
Uh,
in the sense that Hobbs data and locked it and resell criticized them,
uh,
for doing rather he's saying
you and me considering ourselves as we are.
If the state didn't exist,
what kind of state would we create?
We know it's a thought experiment.
We know it's a hypothetical exercise.
Nonetheless,
if we can answer that question,
it gives us a standard by which we can compare existing institutions that didn't
come about in that way.
Right.
From the standpoint of this normative ideal of consent,
what would people have chosen,
even though they never did choose?
It tells us,
uh,
something about existing institutions,
namely those that are closest to what people would have chosen are better.
And those are further from what people would have chosen are worse.
So it's,
it's this search for a normative ideal based on an hypothetical contract.
Whereas Hobbes and Locke thought the state of nature,
was it a condition that has had actually existed in the world and to which
people could return?
Hobbes thought,
uh,
England during the civil war actually went into a state of nature lock thought
much of numeric.
North America in the 17th century was in a state of nature.
So it's a very different exercise in that sense.
It's a hypothetical social contract,
not an actual one designed to generate a normative standard,
a standard for evaluating institutions as they exist in the real world.
That's all.
So that's the first thing.
You have to have an answer to this.
There never was a social contract critique.
And the answer of the modern social contracts theorists is,
yes,
we know,
but it's still a useful hypothetical exercise.
The other problem than anyone rolling out a social contract theory has to
address is that nobody really buys natural law arguments in the way that was
often hoped that they would.
Now it's important to get clear about this because what we don't want to do is
buy into a rather simplistic,
a comic strip version of the history of ideas that is sometimes shows up in
textbooks.
The comic Strip version goes something like this,
while they used to be natural law theory and that solved the problem of where,
of how we get higher values for judging existing institutions.
But then along came the decline of Natural Law and secularism and we lost belief
in natural law.
And so now,
um,
we,
everything's a sea of relativism.
You know,
once you start down that path,
you wind up with Stevenson,
you wind up with remember emotive ism and all that talked about it in relation
to male.
Once you start down the path of rejecting natural law,
you're going to wind up with extreme relativism.
And subjectivism,
you're going to wind up with the idea that everybody's moral judgment is just as
good as everybody else's.
And the problem with natural law theory is it's a throwback to this era when
people believed in natural law.
And so,
uh,
you know,
now people don't and that's the problem.
And so how can you generate a natural law theory,
um,
when most people don't.
The idea of natural law,
that's the cartoon strip story and the cartoon strip story has one very big
problem with it,
which you are in a position to know about because of what we've read with
respect to lock,
namely that there never was agreement on what natural law are required.
I talked to you about the d the disagreement between those who favored the
timeless universal conception of natural law and those who favored the so-called
voluntourist or workmanship theory that lock embraced.
But actually that's only the tip of the iceberg.
You go and read a book like Richard Tux Book on many evil natural law theory.
And what you'll discover is that in in the 16th and 15th,
16th,
17th centuries,
the disagreements that they had within the national law tradition about
politics,
we're just as extensive as the disagreements we have today.
That is to say you could find people defend a everything from what we think of
today as the far left to everything that we think of today as the far right
within the ADM of a natural law.
MMM.
A natural law of vocabulary.
But there wasn't less disagreement,
there wasn't less political disagreement.
There were huge political disagreements that led to enormous two civil wars to
religious wars,
um,
in the,
in the 16th and 17th centuries.
So then notion that appealing to an actual law is some sort of
mmm
panacea and that the problem is that the world we've lost is a world in which
there was natural law doesn't get us anywhere because we know,
we know that natural law,
um,
whatever,
it's,
its virtues and deficiencies is not something that can solve political
disagreements.
As I said,
there was a natural law theory that was compatible with every political position
you could even imagine and many that you couldn't imagine,
uh,
which existed if,
if you want.
Uh,
and he's,
uh,
examples of that going read Christopher hills book called the world turned
upside down,
which is a book about ideas and political movements that got nowhere in the 17th
century.
Um,
and you'll,
you'll see that a natural law,
uh,
could,
could be lined up with,
with any,
any politics you could possibly imagine.
Okay.
So that we don't want to,
we don't want to say that the problem is that natural law used to constrain and
now it doesn't because people agreed.
We know that they didn't.
Nonetheless.
Yeah.
That's still leaves the analytical that if they're going to be any constraints
on what it is that people are,
can agree to that and not simply the result.
Yeah.
Of what we have.
We have found in the world,
they must come from somewhere.
And if you're going to roll out a natural law theory that doesn't depend upon,
um,
natural law,
you've got to find some other basis for doing it,
right?
I mean,
just,
just to give you,
you one more example to underscore this,
we saw that,
um,
that that inequalities among people.
You know,
we talked about this Simon,
we're going to talk about it more in connection with John Roles.
There are a big problem for us,
um,
because why should some people get more than others just because they are
smarter or more hardworking than others?
Right?
If you're a lock in,
there's no problem with that proposition because if some people are more able to
create things wealth than others,
it must've been part of God's plan,
right?
Um,
but why don't you secularize workmanship and chop off the idea of natural law
and God's plan and all that.
Then you get into the sorts of problems we got into when we were dealing with
Marx's theory of exploitation.
Remember when we introduced the,
these stay at home spouse and the,
and the,
uh,
contributions of Sunday school teachers or anybody else to the creation of
value.
We got this over determined set of entitlements that didn't lead us anywhere.
So why don't you second arise,
um,
workmanship it seems,
it seems to lead everywhere.
If you,
you no longer have the constraint that lock had.
Well this what we see here must be God's plan because this is how he created it.
So what are you going to use instead?
That's the question.
Why are you going to use instead of natural law and the modern social contract
theorists,
a pl two and 19th century German philosopher called Emmanuel Kant.
Okay.
18th and 19th century.
Thank her.
Who um,
came up with an idea that stands in for natural law
and that is the idea of
white for it.
I,
I told you people don't like to say in words of one syllable what can be setting
what words of five universalize ability yearn a versa lies at bail at t nine
syllable word.
And the,
the basic intuition here is the following.
The basic intuition is
if you could choose something from every conceivable standpoint,
then it has the force of a moral law.
Anyone know what the philosophical term for this was?
That comment came up with,
yeah.
Anyone who took a philosophy course.
Categorical imperative.
Okay,
so the idea was,
well,
why was it,
why was the categorical imperative contrasted with
somebody?
Anyone know?
No,
no reason that you should,
the categorical imperative was contrasted with the hypothetical imperative and
the idea of a hypothetical imperative was if then,
so you know,
if you want your society to thrive,
don't create big government.
That's a hypothetical imperative.
Categorical imperative is don't create big government ever under any
circumstance.
Okay.
So the idea of a categorical imperative is that it's not dependent on an if then
statement,
right?
So that's the notion behind [inaudible] ethics that we should look for
propositions that we would affirm regardless of the consequences.
That's the notion of a categorical imperative.
Now,
rolls goes into this in some detail and what its implications are for
contemporary political theory,
and we'll talk about that after the break.
Nozick just takes it for granted.
And one of the reasons I'm starting with Nozick is I don't really want to dig
into the question yet of whether and to what extent cons,
ideas are applicable to contemporary politics.
Nozick says,
let's just take it,
just try him out and see.
It's basically,
so you know,
one of his slogans is Kantianism for people,
utilitarianism for animals,
right?
That the,
and the notion here is for human beings,
this idea of respecting,
uh,
principles that can be a,
from from every point of view that's kind of replace natural law.
Okay.
That's nozicks that's the move that Nozick makes since the move that roles makes
as well.
Did anyone happen to know what the famous categorical imperative was?
The example that con gave
okay.
Of something that rises to this level of a categorical imperative is just merely
hypothetical.
Well,
the example he gave was always treat others as ends in themselves,
not merely as means to your own ends.
Sometimes this,
the bumper sticker for this is autonomy.
Treat people as respect people's autonomy.
This is our rights piece of the rights.
Utility tends to synthesis,
right?
We s and he and cons view wise that is a proposition everybody would affirm
regardless of the empirical consequences,
regardless of what effects it has,
you'll always say that no matter who you are that we should respect the autonomy
about this,
uh,
understood in this way.
Uh,
yes,
we,
we all have to use one another to some extent.
He doesn't say never use people as means.
Your Nancy says never use people exclusively as mainstay around ends.
So that's his example and that's what Nozick takes over in his conception of
individual liberty,
which he puts out there,
uh,
right at the beginning of anarchy state and Utopia when he says there is no
social entity where the good that undergo some sacrifice for its own good.
They're are only individual people,
different individual people with their own individual lives using one of these
people for the benefit of others uses him and benefits others.
Nothing more.
So is a strong libertarian stance identified with this Kantian or notion of
respecting the autonomy of others?
We can't use people for some greater God because then we're using them.
We are violating their rights.
And this is where Nozick is,
is headed.
And what he does is disarmingly simple
and,
and easily dismissed.
Then you make a mistake if you dismiss him because you'll your not say,
uh,
what turns on some of his claims that turns out to be a very interesting and
important.
So what he does is he says,
let's imagine there was no government.
We're not talking about primitive people were talking about people like you and
me.
Let's imagine there's no,
there was no government.
What would happen?
What would people do if there was no government?
Okay.
And Nozick is aware,
he is aware that you could make different about that.
Like Hobbes makes the assumption and Leviathan that people will be so afraid of
one another,
that they will try and kill it,
kill everybody around them.
Then you'll get civil war.
That the,
the fear that others are going to do something to you will be so great that,
um,
unless you,
unless you impose an authoritarian state on people,
they're going to have a civil war and there's no,
there's no other possibility.
And so by making the state of nature very benevolent,
Locke thinks he's going a different way because by,
by making it malign,
it's easy for Hobbs to justify authoritarianism.
You know,
the state of nature is so terrible that anyone would put up with
and authoritarian system rather than the civil war in which life is solitary,
poor,
nasty,
brutish,
and short as Hobbes put it in Leviathan.
So Nozick says,
let's not do that.
Let's go with Locke and let's make the state of nature relatively benign because
it will make our argument more convincing.
It'll make our argument more convincing because if you make the state of nature
relatively benign,
it's harder to justify
the creation of a state.
And we want to make it hard for ourselves to justify the creation of a state
because then it'll make our argument more convincing to skeptics,
right?
So we want to make this intellectual problem is hard for ourselves as we
possibly can.
Now there's something of an intellectual slide of hand going on in this that I'm
going to come back to,
but I'll just flag for right now that in the way he sets it up,
uh,
he,
he says,
let's make it hard to derive a,
the idea of a state.
So he says,
imagine,
imagine a world in which there's no government.
It's a hard thing for us to do.
Okay.
Just,
just to make this real,
do you know when police were created,
the first police force was created in Britain was before he,
before here,
no reason.
You should.
prime minister peel created the,
the first police were called PLRs name for the prime minister.
But imagine just you think about it.
Think about living in a world where there were no police.
I mean,
it'd be a very,
very different world.
All right,
cool.
Uh,
think about the w the ways in which,
just just in a day in new haven,
the number of things that go on that is somehow affected by the hovering
presence of police.
So that,
that's the kind of,
and so Nozick wants you to do that in a more radical way.
Think that,
imagine what would,
what would happen if there was no government?
Uh,
well,
it wouldn't be a very efficient circumstance
even if
we don't think that everyone would be out shopping one another,
two pieces with machetes.
It still wouldn't be a very efficient situation because everybody would be the
enforcer of natural law themselves since the Lockian story,
as you know.
Um,
so if I were in here lecturing to you,
I'd have to worry,
you know,
maybe somebody,
maybe somebody grabbing my car and making off with that.
So I would have to,
you know,
find some way to protect my car while I was sitting here doing this and problem.
Maybe I could do it,
but it's kind of a very inefficient thing for me to do.
Um,
and so how am I going to do that?
How,
how is,
how is life going to go on if people can even know that their property is going
to be protected?
Well,
they're gonna form protective associations that Garneau say,
okay,
I'm,
I'm gonna,
you know,
I'm going to say there was some colleague,
I'll tell you what,
you'll watch my car on Mondays and Wednesdays while I'm lecturing and I'll watch
your car,
you know,
sort of block watch kind of idea.
Right?
People are going to form associations to protect themselves and to protect their
property because in the absence of that,
it's very inefficient.
Highly inefficient system.
Okay.
So you would imagine
they would,
they would sort of be a,
they would basically be like block watch,
but even that,
you know,
would be not particularly efficient because the truth is not only do I not want
to watch my car on Mondays and Wednesdays,
I don't really want to watch somebody else's car and Tuesdays and Thursdays
either.
Right?
So what would happen is we would start to have a division of labor.
We would start to have a situation in which we paid somebody to watch cars,
right?
And that they would be sort of like little malicious.
They would,
um,
the businesses that salt protection.
And so we,
you know,
you could imagine,
uh,
a group of us joining wine association that promises to protect cars,
but others would join a different association that promise to protect cars.
You know,
so we'd have the new haven business that sells carp protection,
but we'd have the ham didn't one and we'd have the orange one and there would be
these different businesses selling protection for people's cars.
Bye.
And this is
okay.
One of nozicks most important analytical claims with application to politics.
He says the thing about coercive force protection
yeah.
Is that it's a natural monopoly.
What is he,
what do you think he might mean by that?
Anyone?
Okay.
Kind of an AI.
It's bringing an economist category.
Do you think about a noneconomic topic,
but what do you think he might mean?
Anyone want to try?
This might seem puzzling.
Think about a country in which there are many malicious,
like Lebanon in the 1980s or Russia after the collapse of the Soviet Union where
you've got these organized crime syndicates more or less,
or Chicago for that matter during the Hay Day of organized crime.
What happens when you have multiple entities selling protection?
Yeah.
I can take the microphone and say,
say,
yeah,
they start fighting with each other.
It's like,
okay,
they start fighting with each other.
Why you're dead.
Right?
But why do they fight with each other?
It's like fighting over territory.
You know,
why territory,
what else?
If one member gets in a fight within member from someone now that from a
different group,
they have to protect that member and sort of is the other group.
So they have no other choice but to fight each other.
Exactly.
Right.
So,
uh,
I mean,
you just go and watch a movie like the Godfather,
Goodfellas or any of those.
And you know what the dynamic is?
I say to you,
you know,
you pay me protection money and I'll make sure you're taken care of.
But then,
you know,
some bigger thug comes around the next day and says,
you might think Shapiro can protect you,
but you know,
what do you think,
you know,
that that went on?
The Yale Faculty can do for you?
Uh,
forget about it.
you're going to pay me.
And what's more,
you going to pay me much more.
And so that's kind of go on.
And how will it end
generally?
What happens?
Yeah,
exactly.
In civil wars,
somebody wins usually,
or I'll say they drag on,
but eventually somebody wins.
Right?
That's the claim about a natural monopoly of force.
That coercive,
full coerce,
a forced to be a good,
it has to be exercised as a monopoly for coercive force to be a good,
it has to be exercised as a monopoly and that's one claim Nozick wants to make.
Okay.
And the other one,
which is just as important
is it is the only natural monopoly.
Coercive force is a natural monopoly where we unpack that to say,
in order for it to be a good,
it has to be exercised as a monopoly and there's no other
natural monopoly.
This morning I,
when I was coming in,
Glenn back was complaining.
How many of you know who Glen back yet?
Yeah.
Who's,
who does it?
Who wants it?
Who's clammed back?
How many you want to tell us?
It was Glenn Beck.
Okay.
Anybody?
Yeah,
he's a conservative talk show hosts.
And it just a social commentator in general.
He's a conservative talk show host and social commentator who sees himself as
kind of disciplining the Republican party to keep it close to what he sees as
conservative principles that are defined in a strongly libertarian way.
And so what was his complaint this morning?
His complaint was that Mike Huckabee,
okay.
Had Michelle Obama on his show or oil or data,
some event with Michelle Obama agreeing with Michelle Obama that obesity is a
big problem in America.
And he said,
how damn Mike Huckabee do that?
Of course,
obesity is a big problem in America,
but
okay,
that doesn't mean it's an invitation for the government to get involved in
stopping obesity.
The government should only do one thing,
protect us from the bad guys.
Okay.
In that sense,
he was,
he's probably never heard of Nozick and,
and,
and all of nozicks argument,
but he was embracing this idea that coercive force is the only natural monopoly.
Okay.
So,
okay.
Yeah.
Nozick wants to say,
if we'd go back into a thought experiment,
he was,
he wants to say,
because coercive force is a natural monopoly,
somebody going to win.
They're going to eat a,
you know,
buy up the other protective associations or defeat them,
wipe them out.
Yeah.
Right.
Or marginalize them,
make them irrelevant.
Um,
by being so,
so much more powerful that nobody pays attention to them.
So in effect,
you're then going to have one dominant protective association,
right.
Okay.
Once you have one dominant protective association,
it's something pretty,
pretty much like a government,
but still they're going to be some people who don't recognize it.
And these are the people that Nozick calls independence
and the nos expends a lot of time discussing these people.
And you might think why there's this very long and difficult to understand
chapter on the incorporation of independence into his system.
And you will,
you will find it confusing to read and you'll think there's something wrong with
you that you can't follow it.
Actually,
the conf,
even though most of what knows,
his rights is extremely clear.
That confusion is nozicks.
Um,
so you shouldn't beat yourself up too much.
And I'm going to,
I'm going to unpack it in more detail on Wednesday,
what he,
what he's saying and why it matters.
Um,
but this is the basic intuition.
He has to worry about independence for two reasons.
One is,
um,
just to complete his account of the,
how the government would form,
but the other one is normative because remember that the social contract
argument depends on the idea of consent.
Remember we said you'd utilitarian tradition is maximizing happiness.
The Marxian tradition is about ending exploitation.
The social contract tradition is about consent as the basis for political
legitimacy.
So even if the holes story about the force being a natural monopoly is correct,
there's still going to be sort of,
you know,
looney principled south there who don't recognize the legitimacy of the state.
You have to worry about Nozick writing in 1974 isn't thinking about the sorts of
people were thinking about today,
um,
in this connection.
And so he talks about,
um,
you know,
some anarchist wandering around,
uh,
who wants to protect their own rights.
Um,
and it,
it has something of a contrived quality to it in his discussion.
But think about when you read independent think Osama bin Ladin or the,
or the,
uh,
Mr Stack who flew his plane into the IRS building the other day.
These are nozicks independence.
These people,
they say,
we don't recognize the legitimacy of your state.
We don't recognize what you were,
you,
your protective association,
we're not going to accept it.
These people are a big problem for Nozick.
And he says,
as I said,
both as a,
as a sort of empirical theoretical matter.
He's saying what,
you know,
what would happen with these people but then as a normative matter as well.
So He's,
so what is he,
what is his point about compensation and all of that?
Um,
I'm going to dig into that on Wednesday.
I'm just going to tell you now briefly,
cause we're out of time.
What happens?
He's,
he's getting basically say these people are going to be forcibly incorporated
into the social order.
Yeah.
And the theory of compensation is an account of what makes that enforceable
incorporation legitimate.
And I'll dig into that on Wednesday.
Okay.
We're out of time now,
so we'll pick up with that.
Uh,
right at the beginning.
Cheers.